we begin this half hour with a visit to
windsor castle just west of london it's
where britain's queen elizabeth spends
many of her private weekends
it's also home to a stunning display of
flowers and trees
starting this weekend and lasting for
the next few weeks the public
will be allowed to get a rare look at
the castle gardens
and what makes them so special
windsor castle one of queen elizabeth's
official residences
home to ceremonies full of pageantry and
tradition
including the 2018 wedding of prince
harry
and meghan markle it's also known for
its stunning gardens
including one that's been closed to the
public for decades
until today for the first time in 40
years the queen is allowing commoners
the chance to explore her beloved east
terrace gardens
right in her own backyard various
generations of the royal family have
actually looked into this garden
from the apartments up above and also
it's been a quiet spot we're on the far
side from the town of windsor and the
main road
it's not overlooked so it gives a nice
sense
of privacy and a bit of a retreat as
well a nice quiet spot to come to
the formal plantings include clip domes
of yew trees
immaculate lawns and over 3 500 rose
bushes planted in a geometric pattern
around a central fountain it's all the
result of generations of royal
influence it's originally created by
george iv
extensively remodeled by queen victoria
and prince albert
but it's in the 20th century its current
look
was very much responsibility of the duke
of edinburgh so he effectively
redesigned it
in 1971 laying out the design
of the rose beds the queen's own
alterations were only temporary
as a child during world war ii she and
sister margaret cultivated crops in
their very own
victory garden the garden was completely
dug over
in order to plant vegetables and there
were two
separate uh plots set aside for the
young princess elizabeth
and her sister the princess margaret and
they grew sweet corn and tomatoes
beans as well i think all as part of the
war effort doing their doing their bit
it may be one reason why the area
remains special to her
but at the moment she's not around to
enjoy it after her own coronavirus
lockdown at windsor
the queen and prince philip have
decamped to their summer retreat
balmoral castle in scotland leaving
non-royals
to get the royal treatment it's pretty
cool right
very cool and the fact that it hasn't
been open in more than 40 years you
would think it would have been open this
whole time and now opening it during a
pandemic
doesn't seem i know necessarily sure
there'll be some precautions taken
i'm sure there will be cool place to see
though